okay he's got a distance for me 3.2 yeah
okay good
now before I've been the three point you
on where does it go I need to draw some
more stuff on you yep so just like
before I need more I need more blue tape
just like before I'm going to need an
easterly line so I'm gonna move this out
of the way and then I need to complete
this right angle triangle in here right
which of the legs is it it's the bottom
one right there's the you said three
points you alright now the next question
doesn't require any more trigonometry
okay what they're asking for is not how
far each the X is why not how far east
of Y is Z they want to know the total do
you see that read the question they say
how far east of X is that does that make
sense yeah the whole distance so I'm
actually gonna put on another set of
lines over here like so you see that so
it's this was six no five point six that
was three points so what's the total
eight point eight okay so let's actually
do it
okay it's alright now the next part of
the question Part B is a little bit
repetitive they ask you to do the same
thing but what they want is these
vertical distances in step I'm going to
save us some time too it's the same idea
I'm gonna get straight to the end of
that question so we can look at the
final part was where it's interesting
those vertical distances are adding up
to here down at your diagram as well so
you have that alongside my distance okay
so I just sort of skip Part B and
eventually this is what you end up with
crossways I know it's eight point eight
up and down north-south I've got five
point though okay now can you yeah
okay so Part B is about working out this
and then working at this and then you
add them but because the process is the
same as what we just did I'm sort of
skipping now the final question can you
read Part C or we have a look at it
closely
reading is a really important part in it
what are they asking okay so where are
we going to have to construct on this
diagram to enter party directly from X
suppose they take one up all the way up
let's see if we can do this that's
alright
straight from X is it okay number one
I'm going to find the distance number
two I'm going to find eight Barry
fantastic you can see by virtue of the
second principle drawing a nice decent
diagram what is this whole thing the
whole thing it's one big right angle
triangle
yeah so I'm trying to find out exit now
yeah this long distance here so I'm
gonna go on a squared plus B squared it
was C squared you happy with that so how
much you got I'll write that out for you
what I want the hypotenuse yeah we would
go in somewhere multi-part questions
always do this right have you got the
vibe of this I'm doing this and this so
that I can get to here like so calculate
on this someone beats me
have you already taken a square root you
very take the square root for cash at
home you've got some number here and
then after that ten points I'll do one
discipline and by the way one of the
reasons why I sort of learn who is
because if this acquit nays the
hypotenuse has to be longer yeah okay
good so there we go at happy times the
last question I think that was part one
last question is what what are they
asked me they want the bearing from the
start to the finish
how should I do that yeah so this is the
whole point right
so we want the bearing dog's-eared from
X a curette okay so where's that angle
where is the
where do I travel the angle is from
Frank's Frank so I'm starting over here
from the to exit right cxn is the name
of this line because it's for next
season now this angle is muck inside the
triangle do you say that it's not inside
the big triangle I just made okay but it
is equal to one of the angles that is
inside the Train which one
yeah the alternate one that's right up
in the corner okay
draw it carefully because it's the big
triangle some pretty sure it's this one
that one there do you see it so how
would you like me to actually I don't
have a name for that
um let's call this point over here let's
call this paper point what's the name of
the angle I'm finding out he said X I
think P said X is that all right so the
angle I'm after is P X how am I gonna
find out its size
I'm going to use trig I actually have
all the sides it is triangle now now
that I've done this I could use side
that'd go opposite on my pockets I could
use closed without a go p-- adjacent one
of that pup news or I could use tan
which is opposite and adjacent okay just
as a point of it's a minor point you
really could have used any of those I'm
going to choose ten because I found
these distances first so they're the
least approximated as it were so I'll
get the best accuracy that way
okay so at an opposite what adjacent
[Music]
you're going to get a number out of that
and then what you want is the angle
afterwards so you're gonna have to press
shift an has someone got a science for
me okay we're just going closest degrees
I'll say news degree now at this point I
think everyone here different ones okay
but just a minor thing I'm gonna reread
the question this is not actually the
angle I was asked for was I right even
though it's the same size the actual
angle has hospitals over here so I'm
going to just conclude this off just
like the conclusion in an essay I'm
gonna say therefore the bearing of Zed
from X or you could say from X to Z
either of those are fine is how to write
this
either visit okay hey happy we did it
okay
so let me post your over there it's a
long question it's got many parts that's
because there are so many angles and
lengths to work out this is typical of
various questions so Barry's question
you guys will encounter look we work for
five six marks split across several
parts just like this one is okay